I think Khaleesi will be sitting at the  head she has the dragons even though the  dead has dragons also for likely sea  dragons are going away in the battle  I got Jon Snow taking it Jon Snow when  Jon Snow and the dragon queen I think  Jon Snow actually might be the last one  he might be the king oh stop  that'll be Jon Snow I have no clue  that's the best part about it you can't  figure it out  right like who write think I can't tell  you yet right now we're gonna see Tyrion  Lannister curve ball ends up on the  throne but I also love Arya Stark so one  of them hoping for one of them to end up  on the throne a leader of the White  Walkers night king he's gonna end up  victorious Oh Jonathan lease you bought  the pop get off Marv you think is gonna  be the Ice King just so they can just  say screw you guys